oh that's awful that is so bad
well does that meant to be a good beer
hi lad Bible I'm Margot Robbie I'm gonna
be eating a load of Australian and
British snacks and telling you which is
the far superior one which I'm pretty
sure will be the Australian ones but we
can test it out shapes versus space
Raiders only 20 p mm I really like that
this might be a rare occasion when the
non-australian snacks winning space
Raiders win if I was an Olympian I would
love to be a pole vaulter because that
looks like the kind of sport that defies
physics and gravity and logic this looks
like fun solo classic vs. iron brew so
it's cold okay see nice I know I love
solar I love solar so much 100% solar
100% would I ever star in a James Bond
film notify was gonna be a Bond girl
probably being James Bond oblique
although James Hammes verse penguins Tim
Tams amazing so good now my husband
thinks that penguins are better because
they come with a joke why was the
Penguins head so cold nothing where do
they say the answer I'm probably just an
idiot and I'm missing it doesn't even
come close
Tim times are far superior for if I'm
reading my ice skating skills out of ten
and if one is you know complete amateur
and 10 is Olympics I would say maybe I'm
like a 5 right in between all right
oh it's just gonna be that kind of
reveal 4x about as classic as it gets in
Australia versus John Smith's I don't
know John Smith's Yorkshire smooth
again it just tastes like home to me and
I have so many great memories associated
with it oh that's awful that is so bad
does that meant to be a good beer not to
offend anyone up north I love going out
and then just a bit just I would highly
recommend you try for X and future I
don't think anyone's ever chatted me up
in infernos which is kind of sad for me
because standards aren't particularly
high at infernos just cleanse the palate
Oh classic on my left we have the
Australian staple Vegemite pretty
intense to eat it on its own I have to
say usually it goes on toast or on
crackers but uh mhm tastes like my
childhood and over here I'm guessing
this is Marmite
yeah I do enjoy Marmite I'm not gonna
lie actually like Bovril a lot too
but this is just it tastes like home so
I have to I have to give it to Vegemite
I'm afraid I may be biased maybe but I'd
say that the Australian snacks are their
superior thanks lad Bible thanks for
having me
[Music]